la question que tout le monde se pose à
lui a bien sûr été posée ce matin c'est
à voir s'il a envie d'être candidat il
se voit président de la république on va
voir sa réponse là et vous allez nous
dire parce que quand il a vu les
sondages ont atteint les 10%
d'intentions de vote on va il s'est dit
là je vais pas hésiter
des minutes comme ça vous vous imaginez
à l'elysée
c'est pas une question que je me pose
ainsi la question ne se pose pas ainsi
la question ne se pose pas en reste que
je n'imagine à l'elysée où est ce que je
n'imagine dans un taudis de 2,2 de la
banlieue parisienne non la terre n est
pas l'immeuble le problème ce sont les
idées et se sont laissé l'état de la
france est il possible que vous ne soyez
pas candidat mais tout est possible que
vous décidiez de ne pas l'être mais bien
sûr parce que tout simplement je ne
ferai pas une candidature de témoignage
mais l'état ne peut défendre vos idées à
votre place quelqu'un peut les défendre
alors que justement le problème c'est
que ça fait 30 ans que j'attends et que
personne ne les défends ou dit cui sa
marque dans le pen ne gagnera pas marine
le pen ne gagnent pas
vous un des amis et des règlements vous
pensez qu'il va y aller ou pas mais en
fait cyril il n'est même pas encore
candidat qu'on voit déjà que tout
système se met en marche pour essayer de
lui et de lui casser la tête et donc je
comprends qu'il hésite je comprends
qu'ils réfléchissent parce que le jour
où il annoncera peut-être sa candidature
vous imaginez ce qui va prendre jusqu il
prend déjà assez fine des dons film six
jeunes en plus de 6 au 9
mai les crises au figaro il était hier
chez pro il était celle du
juste et quand on est victime d'une
décision injuste et ben on est victime
amelia la loi des séries bâlois
messieurs n'y a pas de loi et l'esprit
de la loi non surtout pas il ya une loi
qui permet de décompter le temps des
candidats le moment de la campagne venu
et là on vient d'inventer quelque chose
spécialement pour nier la vérité on peut
le regretter mais monsieur a raison le
deux poids deux mesures il vous que pour
exister vrai c'est lui qui ont acheté
mes pires imposer des gels et très malin
ça ne dessert pas plus quelque chose est
arrivé bon de montrer ma soeur
cette faute en fait c'est de votre faute
que c'est un salon vous n'auriez pas
mille affiches n'auriez pas créé les
amis d'eric zemmour bah il serait pas
quand on n'en parle pas mais moi je vais
vous dire un truc nourrit droite moi je
vais vous dire un truc je vais vous dire
un truc très simple et je vous racontais
l'histoire bas on va on va dire les
choses ici on arrête de voile à défaire
de la langue de bois les mecs on arrête
je vous dire eric zemmour si frais satie
faisait cinquante mille téléspectateurs
tous les jours sur ces
droits que le reste est là-bas pendant
20 ans
lobbying extrêmement puissant des autres
chaînes d autres groupes d eau ou tout
simplement parce que eric zémour nous on
découvre on le sait et le surinam ans
jeudi a dit on est complètement voilà on
est complètement aux antipodes de ce
dîner mais ça ne nous empêche pas de
discuter avec les essayer et d'essayer
voilà de ne pas voilà de discuter avec
lui et d'essayer de voir pourquoi il
pense à quelque chose et nous lui
exposer notre notre notre notion sujet
aussi mais le problème aujourd'hui
qu'eric zemmour c'est qui fait tous les
jours entre 810 et un binôme sur ces
nouilles d'ailleurs demain eric zemmour
il aurait été soixante quinze mille
téléspectateurs
non je peux vous dire que personne
n'aura rien dit à eric zemmour il aurait
été là pendant dix ans et personne
touche pas à mon pote
mais donc je savais que ce sont les
autres chaînes qui ont fait pression sur
le csa pour dire eczéma va se présenter
on a des preuves qui va se présenter on
va vous montrer les preuves qui va se
présenter et que ça va un moment s'est
retrouvé dans une situation inextricable
sony qu'est ce qu'on fait combien en
cours on continue à voir ce lobbying des
autres chaînes et des autres groupes
d'audiovisuel qui sont gênés par eric
des mois qui sert de ça pour dire qu'il
va se présenter ou bien on laisse faire
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui eric
zemmour était huit cent mille contre
1100 milles 1 million téléspectateurs et
ça dérange on va pas se mentir on a eu
un problème avec bfm un moment tout le
monde s'est mise sur bfm pourquoi parce
que bfm cartonné donc ton de ces livres
on va taper sur bfm et tout le monde est
devenu jaloux de fl aujourd'hui c'est
ses news on est passé par là également
nous quand on était sur france 4 vous
dire à faire soixante dix mille
téléspectateurs arabes en été mais tout
le monde a un secret générale 1 voilà
est forcément un moment je vous dis dabo
coup de lobbing aussi des autres chaînes
et on a eu souvent ce cas de figure même
autour de nous et au contrôle - et donc
il faut pas se mentir les mecs voilà
eric zemmour le c'est ça l'art est pas
ce qu a eu des pressions des autres ce
qui fait les grosses audiences c'est
tout
les réserves de saint-cyrille c'est que
ce que vous dites est juste et qu'en
plus du coup comme il n'a plus rien ça
crée un vide dans lequel qui va lui
permettre peut-être de se présenter
alors que dans certains dans son
entourage aujourd'hui il est peut-être
celui qui avait le moins envie d'y aller
et or là tout le pousse à ce qui se
passe entre elles réellement eric
zemmour il a certes une tribune il avait
certes une tribune sur ses new skies
quatre à cinq fois par semaine mais les
autres gars aussi long des tribunes on
les voit sur les mains sur ces îles sont
avant
tout à faire le calcul du temps
d'antenne des candidats dans les autres
chaînes ça n'empêche pas de tente rien à
voir aux quatre conteneurs
l'heure tous les soirs je mets le seul
problème les zones à aujourd'hui c'est
qu'eric zemmour n'était pas candidat
donc aujourd'hui comme l'a dit le
monsieur du c'est ça moi je m'en fous
qui réglait mon sens mondaine ou pas
voilà mais je vous dis comme l'a dit le
monsieur du csa excessif mais un vice de
forme est complet on est en train de
très fort mais je le redis la
potentielle d'un problème juridique et
je crois que je lis et encore ça c'est
le lobby voilà des autres chaînes s'il
ya quelqu'un qui a joué - cé mais on à
paris soit on a plus qu'un problème joue
vraiment avec cyril on a un problème
politique c'est à dire que la politique
elle est partout elle est là elle est
sur l'ensemble des chaînes et toutes les
autres chaînes notamment celle du
service public font de la politique avec
des chroniqueurs qui le matin à la radio
vous l'écoutez quand vous allez au
gauche au but robin promeuvent des idées
de gauche eric zemmour était le seul à
la télé à promouvoir des idées de droite
et donc ce qui m'embête c'est que au
delà de la question juridique on
supprime un courant de pensée
complètement aujourd'hui à la télé
58 % non à 41% merci antoine diers cela